Las Vegas a city where the nightlife
seems to be never ending and tourists
are always stopping by but being in such
a busy town could always come with
dangers I had this like idea of what
what could we put into a lipstick how
could we keep people safe with literally
a lipstick Joy Hoover is the CEO of SOS
Cosmetics she has worked in Las Vegas
for 13 years she used her passion of
Social Work and cosmetology to come up
with an everyday device that could save
your life you could have a regular
lipstick this is liquid lipstick so it
comes off like that and you can see our
logo on it kind of there but covertly
placed in the base you just have to
click it off this is actually our actual
test strips test strips that can detect
if your drink has been tampered with you
can just open this with your fingernail
put a drop of your drink with your
finger on this and then wait it will
show up pretty immediately but you want
to look for two lines two lines are safe
the lipstick also comes with a panic
button synced up with the SOS app on
your phone it can alert friends and
authorities if you're in trouble yes
test your drink but if you already feel
unsafe just push it push the button the
app on your phone is meant to be
discreet if you ever do find yourself in
a difficult situation a driving force
for this product came from her personal
tragedy Hoover lost her mother-in-law to
domestic violence in 2013. we talked
through like what could have potentially
saved your mom's life he's like I
honestly really think like she could be
here today if we had that happen but
with this new product she hopes she can
save another life just by being
proactive Victoria Saha 8 News Now